hi everyone I'm Anthony Silvano CBS News
elections and surveys directors and
director enjoining me in the Toyota
greenroom is Ashley Edwards refinery29 s
senior news and politics editor we have
teamed up here at CBS News with
refinery29 to explore the impact of
millennial women on the coming midterm
elections Ashley good to see you so we
just finished this poll we just put out
the releases and one of the things that
I think struck everybody was the turnout
question and as we head towards midterms
everybody's always asking matters the
most
yeah the turnout questions visit depends
who shows up right so so millennial
women many of them said that they were
excited enthusiastic about voting but
they were less likely compared to older
women compared to the older generation
what did you make of that and why might
that be I think people are energized
they're angry however that doesn't
necessarily translate into actually
going out to the voting booth they may
not be excited about the candidates that
are up in the 2018 elections so for them
if they may think their vote doesn't
necessarily matter so that could be why
people aren't showing up we've talked to
some women and they just feel like
they're kind of disillusioned from all
sides from Republicans Democrats they
kind of feel like no one's really has
our best interests in mind so why does
it even matter to vote yeah I you know I
was struck by the large number who said
that it didn't matter who controlled
Congress and one of the things I think
we'll be watching as these midterm
campaigns unfold is can the parties make
the argument that it does midterm
turnout as you pointed out and others is
often very low but it starts with that
idea that it matters you know when you
talk to folks and you you wouldn't you
cover politics from refinery29
are there other ways that younger people
are getting involved even if it's not
politics we're what are the channels for
their activism I think that social media
is a huge channel of activism for people
from sharing stories they care about
sharing statuses and then finding out
where protests and things are I think
people really like to show that they
care about issues on social media but
that doesn't necessarily translate into
real life effects like actually going to
the polls actually campaigning for a
candidate but I think people like to say
that they're involved and so if they
actually care
about issues but it's another thing to
actually you know register to vote and
go vote yeah and we saw in the polling
that a lot of these millennial women do
say that they post that they share that
they're engaged but that they recognize
it's not necessarily the most effective
thing it is though easy to do right and
this generation has been raised on
social media social media it's the
easiest way to share how you feel about
things and if you're like reading a news
story and you're really angry and fired
up you're gonna share that but then you
may go home kind of forget about it or
say like does it really matter if I vote
or not and the last affection I voted it
didn't go the way I wanted does it
really actually matter so I think that's
you're seeing that apathy for young
people everywhere so for the folks who
are going to vote and like we said there
are plenty of them you know it struck us
in the polling that they were very
motivated they were very enthusiastic
and that they cared about some
particular you know issues over others
one of them being health care yes so I
think for Otis across the board from
millennial to older women health care
was the most important part over things
like immigration and the economy and
civil rights I think because health care
is very personal
you can either afford to go to the
doctor or you can't or you're gonna end
up going into debt going to the doctor
you have an emergency and I think for
Millennials they see rising healthcare
cost everything is so expensive so they
that's really moving them because it
affects them very personally as compared
to other things that are a little bit
more abstract or in the background and
they see you can't really necessarily
change that quickly right you know
health care one of those issues the
economy as it affects their pocketbook
or this age group - it strikes me it
shows the most change in their lives for
any category that we ever we pollsters
put people in from 18 to 35 right you
might graduate from college if you go to
college you might get your first job buy
your first house you know start a family
all those things and yet it seemed like
the the economic part of it is it really
is all about whether they're affected
yeah and that starts to change over time
but we often see young people not quite
see that connection to politics
it's very immediate and that's wise
things like health care I'm a millennial
and for us like my parents generation
they could buy houses they didn't really
necessarily have to worry that much
about health care
they had more savings our generation
it's kind of we don't really have that
we are saddled with student loan debt so
as health care it affects your pockets
very personally we're really gonna care
about that since so many other things
are out of our control that's one thing
that we see like we really have to care
about yeah and many of them also came of
age after the recession during the the
recovery which didn't help everybody all
at once as well and you know one of the
other things that strikes you too is
this is the most diverse generation
compared to older Americans this
generation is more likely to know
someone or be from a family who are
immigrants right and and the composition
of this generation is the most diverse
it's it's just over
you know half white but also non-white
in large percentages how do you think
that is affecting all of these numbers
that we see today
I think Millennials really care about
identity politics where you're from how
you identify I am a daughter of
immigrants so for me I grew up in a
household of immigrants around
immigrants for older generation that may
not have been the same thing
demographics have shifted so much so for
us it's really visible and that's why
it's more of a thing for us than the
older generation so I think we are going
to the polls to vote for people who
identify with us we see that we kind of
see ourselves in as opposed to older
people may more care about kind of you
know the economy more hard hard issues
and that yeah that sense of familiarity
really impacts opinions we see that even
when we ask in the polling the
immigration question whether they feel
like immigrants contribute to or don't
contribute to society and younger folks
younger women in this poll are more
likely to say that they do and part of
it is is that is that familiarity tell
me also about when when you talk about
gun policy of course that's going to be
another hot topic in this election what
struck you about the findings and
whether people are going to vote on that
or not
so what I found really interesting was
that women across the board think gun
laws should be more strict from younger
to older so I think that for women
that's a huge issue but then when you
break it down by partisan lines
Democrats of course
want it to be more strict Republicans
either want it to be lost to be less
strict or to remain the same but overall
women care a lot about these mass
shootings and gun control and I think
that there's been so many high profile
incidents in the past two years that
it's getting really hard for people to
ignore so I think that with the activism
of the Parkland students people are
really starting to see that their
elected officials can really change
these laws if they want to so for them
they're really voting and coming out for
that yeah speaking of partisan lines one
of the other things we were talking
about earlier was the way in which as
people as voters react to the number of
women candidates who are running this
year which are in record numbers we
found the Democrats a little more likely
than Republicans to say that it would be
a good thing to have more women in
office to talk a little about that and
talk about how why you think that is and
why it is that voters told us that they
thought it would be good to have more
women in office so some people said that
they think it would be good for
democracy because it's a more diverse
pool of people who are in politics
Congress its majority male so if you
have more women elected it's going to be
more split other people said women are
better negotiators so things would
actually get done and then some people
said it it really doesn't matter but I
think the vast majority think that it's
time for it's not just to be a boys club
in Congress for women to finally take
the lead
Republicans were less likely to think
that it matters but then I think overall
people are like it wouldn't be a bad
thing for there'd be more diverse I
think not just gender but of thought in
Congress you know when you look at as
you cover the politics from and also
from the perspective of younger people
what is it that you think defines this
generation that makes them so different
or different from older generations and
what they're looking for and what they
want to hear I definitely think that we
are more connected than the older
generation so there's a lot more
exchange of ideas so we're hearing a lot
more things we're seeing a lot more
things than older people you're kind of
in your community you kind of thought
along the lines of people around you but
now we are so interconnected through
social media that we all are kind of
getting different ideas from all over
and I think that what that's what makes
us more different than any other
generation
and I think that activism online has
connected us but like I said it doesn't
really translate into politics for us
yeah well that sense of community it's
interesting you raise that because for a
long time voting studies have always
shown that once somebody feels like part
of a community they're more likely to
get engaged and more likely to vote and
interestingly enough it doesn't have to
be a physical community yeah now it can
be an online one or a digital one as we
go forward in the midterms
what are you looking for what do you
think is going to be pivotal not just
new controls Congress but in what kinds
of policies come out of this I think I
think healthcare is truly the number one
for me that's one thing I really really
care about and I think that I honestly
haven't heard that many candidates
really pushing home healthcare when
that's the most important thing I've
heard them talking about immigration
I've heard them talking about abortion
but health care has kind of been in the
background so if that's the main thing
that people care about I would like to
see how these different candidates are
going to address that we're almost two
months out so it's time for them to
start talking about that more great ok
everyone this has been the Toyota
greenroom live for with Ashley Edwards
of refinery29
i am anthony savant oh of CBS news with
our latest team up here on polling about
the midterm elections in millennial
women thank you very much for watching
have a good day